welcome back to PGA InDesign today I'm
going to answer a question from Ren
Greenspan if I pronounced correct your
name it's interesting to looking at this
construction for this six prong setting
so what we're gonna do today is kind of
discussed two way to make this type of a
setting are you ready let's get started
so I'm going to walk through my thinking
process on this one with you when we get
this six prong here one thing we can
thinking about is to making each of the
u-shape and then we polar array and then
so that we'll call it done the other way
that we're thinking about is we have a
whole block and we kind of create
certain of a cutting tool and to cut out
the shape like this
so I gonna show you both ways and see
whichever way that you will like it
first of all we bringing the stone and
if you wanted to know how to make the
stone you can look at this video right
here I show you step-by-step making the
stone with all the cuts there so if
you're interested in check out this
video once you have the stone I bring
the stoning whatever the size that you
want it to be my happen to be roughly
about a millimeter something a big
diamond there and then I'm going to
making the surface that go around it so
I'm going to use this command and then
we are going to set it up to the zero
depends on how high you want it I
usually will like to have my prong
longer than the table so that way I will
have the prong enough prone to bend over
so I want to have something like this
and if this is like too tall to you not
like the picture there maybe the girdle
is way too high we may want to scale one
detail and still moving up a little bit
okay so that will be the position that
we have thinking about you're going to
offset in zile alcide you want to make
sure your prong is
curry morning 20% of the prawn thickness
by the stone so that's what we wanted to
look into it alright so now we got that
the second things we wanted to do is we
need to make sure that it's evenly
spread it out for the six prong so let's
do the command going to be divided and
we're gonna divide this other age for
about six of them so we want to make
sure the segment is six and then we
click okay then we get those start there
once we get those stud if you take a
picture if you take a detailed look on
this those that is representing the
location on the top six prong and they
are coming down to the button and the
button is halfway of the six prong so
what we wanted to do is we're gonna pick
up those top six point ctrl-c and ctrl-v
make a duplication and scale them down
like that small I also notice they are
now completely aligned with the bigger
circumference point there so what we
wanted to do is rotate it about thirty
degrees so that will be right in the
middle I also wanted to move those down
roughly somewhere like this okay
so now let me hide the stone and that's
just take the look on this and I'm gonna
hide this one as well as you can see we
have those stuff on the outside those
stuff from inside and we need to draw a
line that is definitely past those point
right so let's go ahead to use the curve
tool you got to curve tool right here
control point curve and interpolate
point at this scenario we want to make
sure we use interpolate point and so
that will go through the point exactly
okay now let's take a look on the
perspective now if I turn on my surface
I could use that to pull back to the
surface
but then when I need to have a thickness
that won't be
accurate enough so what I do to make it
super accurate I'm going to select this
one and project to the sea plane and I
want to delete the input so now they are
completely flat to the bottom so next
things I wanted to do is I want to
extended this curve so that's going to
the extended curve by line and I'm just
needed to go straight because I just
needed to be over the age there and then
so we're gonna do the same thing on the
other side we want to extend it this one
and turn on the smart track so we'll
make sure that they come up the same
high now we have this let's go ahead to
rebuild it so it will be more even let's
go ahead to use try to use seven point
look nice let's click OK
so we are going to make a copy of this
to other layer and then we might need to
use them later on so that's just go
ahead and hide that layer so one thing I
would like to do is I would like to
offset this one so first things is
offset your curve I'm going to make my
prong it's about one millimeter so
offset i'm poss-eye
and four point five millimeter each so
this is the new curve that I get I
always like to rebuild the curve and
make sure they are nice and smooth
alright so now we have this we can pick
up those two and use those two curve to
trim the surface over there so now you
can see we will have this surface over
there let's turn on the stone and see
how that fit in there okay so if that
look all right to you that's making into
the solid by offset the surface and we
want them to coming outside and then we
want to make sure it is solid right so
make sure that's not cutting too much of
a stone and then roughly about
person okay so double check if they look
alright then we can have that using the
polar array and we want to create in six
of them for 360 degree and we can get
something like this if you like this one
that will be great we'll just use this
one but I kind of noticed the top is
fitted perfectly because the curvature
right here you can see you have this
overlap in there right so they may not
be super good this little things over
here is not a problem we can just make a
color to cut it out later on in the
middle that will not be the issue
however that kind of overlapping there
is now what exactly I'm looking for we
can also take a look on the render view
right so the render view it actually
looks fine and if your tutor kind of
polish of that that might be okay but I
just don't like that a little bit
overlapping over there so I'm going to
change another way to do it
the second way we are going to do is
first I need to offset that piece coming
in four point five millimeter after that
I'm going to rebuild this guy to make it
nice and rounded and then I'm going to
extend it the curve by line make this
one just a little bit longer and we're
gonna do the same thing on the other
side make sure you're smart track is on
and then you want to snapping here so
that will be the same high and we want
to close with the line let's go ahead to
join all of them so now this will be our
color before we making the cutter we
want to offset this surface it's called
hair to offset outside and solid equal
yes for one millimeter and we are going
to come in here extrude a planar curve
stray so let's get something like this
alright
let's do a simple test we are going to
pick up the extrusion and we are going
to do polar array six of them Center is
zero type is six of them and see if that
is the shape that we want so let's do
the bowling and pick up this other shape
and also all the cutter so then you will
have this cut it really nicely looking
at this surface right here if the
surface is not what you want you might
need to alter the cutter a little bit so
let's go ahead to pick up the color and
just tilt it a little bit and see if
that come out better and we can again
polar array Center is zero
number four 6360 four six of them and
that's what we get that's two bowling
difference one more timee and let's see
if it is better all right
so you kind of see the angle right there
see if that is the curve you want you
have a little bit extra there we can
just go ahead and delete those little
pieces there okay so once you get that
so once you get that we also need to cut
the ball and design open there so let's
go ahead to duplicate the edges and it's
happened to be the seam that we are
picking up and then so we gotta make a
collar follow this but we don't want to
cut it all the way to the top is somehow
colored somewhere in the middle of it
all just a little bit above the middle
so let's go ahead to split with the
point on this one somewhere about right
here and that's they did this one okay
so now we have this curve
I wanted to pipe it over there but if we
pipe it just stop it right here you're
going to see something like a rounded
finish there if that's what you want
that's fine if not let's go ahead to use
extended curve by line and we want to
pick up this curve and want to go all
the way up so it's continuing of it over
like that long next step we can use the
piping tool we're gonna pipe it
something pretty big over here and then
we're gonna have something really small
over here and that's hit enter and see
what we come up with now we have that
one that's through a test cut maybe I
make the line way too long but all
indifference this one I love this one
and yes I kind of a cut it way too high
maybe I need to go back to make it
shorter but I'm just gonna for this
demonstration I'm going to using that
one so again we want to polar array six
of them 360 degree so all we need to do
is bowling difference and you can take a
look on the render view right now as I
say earlier I might cut it like too tall
mean I wanted to cut it that long and
this is for the printing file that's why
I make the top it's like square and
things like that you need to leave
enough room for your tutor to set the
stone for you I hope you enjoy the video
and I hope Ramba answer your question
thank you everybody for watching check
out my course on my website for the
stone setting if you are interesting
more in the stone setting see you next
time
[Music]